a violent political attack shocks the
nation Joe Scarborough compares
President Trump to 9/11 terrorists and
the Washington Post blames President
Trump for our hurricane I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show well glad
to be back saving the world once again
from the steaming pile that is Michael
Knowles who apparently took over my
radio show for a couple of days in my
absence I just cannot believe that such
things happen well I am gone we'll get
to all of the latest news but first
let's talk about your sleep quality
because the fact is you're sleeping on a
mattress probably built for somebody
else and there's no reason for that
instead you should be checking out
helix-loop-helix sleep has built a sleep
quiz it takes two minutes to complete
they use the answers to match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress whether you're a side
sleeper a hot sleeper whether you like a
plush or firm bed with helix there's no
more guessing and no more confusion all
you have to do is go to helix sleep calm
slash Ben and take their two minutes
sleep quiz and then we'll match you to a
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life I know their
mattresses are great because I have one
my wife and I took the sleep quiz it
arrived in the mail the mattress and
then we opened it up and and just
inflated it right in front of us we
tossed it on the bed frame we were good
to go it's incredibly comfortable
we took a more expensive mattress and
moved it out of our room because the
helix sleep mattress is so good I even
got one for my sister for her wedding go
check it out right now they have a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free as well so
there's really no reason not to do it
right now helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders again 125
bucks off at helix sleep comm slash pen
that's helix sleep calm slash Ben for
125 dollars off your mattress order once
more helix sleep calm slash Ben go check
it out alrighty so we begin today with a
violent attack that if the parties had
been reversed would be national news on
every major channel instead it was sort
of news inside the conservative
ecosystem here is the story according to
CBS San Francisco a man was arrested on
suspicion of felony assault and other
charges after allegedly attempting to
stab a Republican congressional
candidate with a switchblade over the
weekend in Castro Valley according to
the Alameda County Sheriff's Office on
Sunday September 9th at approximately
3:45 p.m. deputies working at the Castro
Valley Fall Festival were alerted to a
possible knife attack at one of the
vendor booths deputies arrived at the
booth and made contact with the victim
Republican candidate Rudy Peters who's
running against incumbent Erik sois well
for the 15th congressional district seat
the Castro Valley news first reported on
the attack according to witnesses 35
year old Castro Valley resident Farzad
Fez le approached Peters at his booth in
an aggressive manner and made
disparaging profanity-laced remarks
about the Republican Party and President
Donald Trump during the incident FFA's
le allegedly pulled out a switchblade
knife and attempted to stab Peters the
knife malfunction the candidate became
involved in a physical struggle with
FFA's le according to the sheriff's
sergeant Ray Kelly the suspect then fled
the scene but was later detained by
deputies and found in possession of a
switchblade knife now this isn't
national news its regional news and the
reason its regional news is because the
guy was cursing about Trump if this has
been an acolyte of President Trump who
is instead attacking a Democrat or a
member of the media this would be
national news because then we'd have a
national conversation about the extent
to which rhetoric on the left is
generating violence and there are some
folks on the right who are qualified to
speak on this for example representative
Steve Scalise the House Majority Whip
Steve Scalise you'll recall it was shot
nearly to death in a congressional
baseball attack they were they were
playing baseball bunch of Congress
people and an anti-trump Bernie Sanders
supporter walked up and started shooting
folks up I said at the time Bernie
Sanders is not responsible for the
actions of a crazy person who decides to
shoot up a bunch of Republican Congress
people but that story disappeared from
the news in about a week in about a week
we would still be talking about that
story if it were a bunch of Democrats
here's Steve Scalise explaining that
some people on the Left incite violence
here's what Scalise had to say he said
you've got some people on the left that
just want this idea of resist and ignore
the fact Trump is president they want to
interrupt the ability of Congress to do
its job and of course you've got death
threats and literal attacks home lives
and frankly I want to see the left stand
up to this and of course Scalise should
know and Scalise is right and this is
not the only evidence of violence and
violent threats coming from folks on the
left again in the media all you hear is
people on the right have grown
increasingly violent thanks to President
Trump's rhetoric and the escalated
rhetoric of recent years you never hear
this about folks on the Left even as
mainstream anchors like Chris Cuomo on
CNN defend an Tifa an actual violent
domestic terror group here's another
story from yesterday according to Ryan
Saavedra over at Daily wire a supporter
of the Democratic socialists of America
has reportedly threatened to shoot up a
make America great again event at the
Trump International Hotel in Washington
DC
law enforcement officials with the
Metropolitan Police Department have
opened up an investigation in response
to the threat which was posted to
Twitter on Tuesday according to the
Daily Mail the Twitter account wrote to
right-wing pundit Cassandra Fairbanks
I'm coming with a gun and I expect to
get numerous blood-stained Magga hats as
trophies the account used the DSA logo
as his profile photo added an emoji of a
rose to its name which is common among
DSA supporters and shortly after the
threat was posted the owner of the
account changed their twitter twitter
handle as well so that's another story
of left-wing threats to violence here's
another one a Republican Party office in
Laramie Wyoming caught fire early
Thursday morning just days after it
opened the Daily Caller news foundation
learned this is a bit of an older story
this one is from September 6th the fire
appears to have been set intentionally
according to Laramie Police Department
spokesman Steve Morgan the local police
department is cooperating with the
Federal Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms in the ongoing investigation
according to Morgan adding that
authorities have not yet identified a
suspect or a motive for the fire that's
not a major shock that have been attacks
on Republican Party offices for the past
several years actually for the last
couple of years there have been attacks
on Republican Party offices and again
the motive of the person who is engaging
in the attack seems to be the only thing
that the media definitely care about if
the person is motivated by pro-trump
animus then that person gets all sorts
of press if the person is motivated by
anti-trump anti right-wing animus then
the person gets no press at all if it
turns out the person was a racist
lunatic then it's a then it's a major
story if it turns out the person was a
left-wing environmentalist Luna lunatic
then the story gets virtually no
coverage and the reason for this is
because well the left does not in most
cases and the vast majority of cases
agree with violent rhetoric the left
does agree with pretty extreme rhetoric
about the right that they would never
tolerate from folks on the right and I
speak today specifically of a column by
Joe Scarborough so Joe Scarborough
yesterday put out a piece in The
Washington Post in which he suggested
the President Trump is harming the dream
of America more than any foreign
adversary ever could his contention is
that Trump is basically worse for
America than 9/11 that is his contention
now again is Joe Scarborough responsible
for violence against proton people no
he's not I have a very simple rule and
I've held this rule consistently since
long before Trump was president
held with regard to Barack Obama if
you're not overtly calling for violence
you're not responsible for violence on
behalf of people who quote-unquote agree
with you because then it's gonna be very
easy to malign mainstream political
opinions because there are a lot of
folks who are crazy who agree with
mainstream political commentators so
instead what I've said and I think this
is the relevant gauge is that you're
only held responsible for the violence
of people who take you up on your offer
of violence or on your urging of
violence then we can fairly say that
rhetoric was involved in violent it is
true however that as we raise the
temperature in the country as we raise
the temperature on the rhetoric there
are people who are on the fringe and
those people are more likely to be
activated by the extreme feeling that
they are getting from the nature of
today's politics think of politics like
ripples in a pond and the epicenter of
those ripples the the very center of
those rules when you throw the rock and
the pond that's a political event and as
um as the ripples move out they
encompass a larger and larger group of
people and I'm from Orem or fringe group
of people so if politics are now
reaching a more fringe group of people
and making those people more apt to feel
extreme more apt to engage in violence
then that's something we ought to be
watching it's one of the reasons we got
to be taking the temperature down at
least a little bit here's Joe
Scarborough though encouraging at least
this this sort of extremism and rhetoric
again this is a guy who it is worthwhile
to recall Joe Scarborough and Mika
Brzezinski an MSNBC spent months pumping
president Trump months pumping President
Trump Joe Scarborough and Mika
Brzezinski had him on the show they sat
with him during the primaries they kept
talking about what a great guy he was
they enjoyed the ratings boost that they
got from hanging out with President
Trump now of course President Trump is
the worst thing since since New Coke
here is Joe Scarborough explaining why
the President of the United States is
worse than 9/11 here's what he said he
said cataclysmic events often bring with
them violent and abrupt endings to
settle the ages and long established
norms those absorbing the impact of
these historical aftershocks readily
grasp the epical changes in real time
who could have imagined during their
commute home on the night of November
21st 1963 that an event in Dallas the
next day would shake the post-war order
guaranteed by America's victory in World
War two even after Lee Harvey Oswald's
shots rang out from the Texas
School Book Depository anyone could have
could anyone have foreseen the collapse
of such an ordered age soon overtaken by
the anarchy of Vietnam the murders of
the Reverend Martin Luther King jr. and
Bobby Kennedy the race riot Chicago Kent
State Watergate post-industrial rot and
the cultural caste set loose across the
country by these events and could even
the most insightful observer have
foreseen while staring at the billowing
smoke set against New York's brilliant
September sky the avalanche of strategic
blunders set in motion by Osama bin
Laden's attack on the United States of
course not but two wars three presidents
and 17 years later the tragic lessons of
that time are still lost on our leaders
and then he goes on to talk about the
United States deploying its its various
resources and how the and how the
various parties dealt with 9/11 but then
he gets to President Trump and here's
what he says 17 years later endless wars
broad and reckless policies at home have
produced annual deficits approaching one
trillion dollars first of all that's a
lie the reason that we actually have a 1
trillion dollar deficit every year is
because of social programs it is not
because of war the reason that we have a
massive massive deficit is not because
of the war it is because of Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid which
constitute somewhere on the order of 66
percent of the federal budget each and
every year in mandatory spending but
Scarborough then continues president
Trump's Republican Party will create
more debt in one year than was generated
in the first 200 years of America's
existence and it's always fun to watch
as people who didn't care all that much
about Barack Obama's debts suddenly care
about Donald Trump's debts and vice
versa by the way Republicans don't care
about that anymore they used to care
about debt an awful lot but the part
that's really astonishing about this
Scarborough column is when he gets it
tore to the end he says for those of us
still believing that Islamic extremists
hate America because of the freedoms we
guarantee to people the gravest threat
Trump poses to our national security is
the damage done daily to America's image
as the New York Times Roger Cohen wrote
the month after Trump's election America
is an idea stripped freedom and human
rights democracy and the rule of law
from what the United States represents
to the world and America itself is
gutted Osama bin Laden was killed by
SEAL Team six before he accomplished
that goal other tyrants who tried to do
the same were consigned to the ash heap
of history the question for voters this
fall is whether their country will move
beyond this troubled chapter in history
or whether they will continue supporting
a politician who has done more damage to
the dream of America than any foreign
adversary ever could
apparently Donald Trump has now done
more to damage America than you know the
murder of 3,000 America
on 9/11 and the murder of Americans by
the way aboard the USS Cole that this
sort of rhetoric is not particularly
helpful I'll give you another example of
this sort of rhetoric in just a second
Donald Trump apparently responsible for
every horrible thing that happens in the
universe it's amazing if the left were
to simply restrict their criticism of
President Trump to the relevant if they
were simply to say you know President
Trump not a supremely confident guy the
people around him maybe keeping him on
track but is this somebody who you
really want to trust is this somebody if
you really trust to make the right
decisions for you they'd have a lot
better shot at winning back power then
they will just screaming to the sky
about how President Trump controls
everything and honestly people on the
right who resonate to this and think
President Trump does control everything
are contributing to a belief that
government can solve all of your
problems when you believe that
government is the only thing that
matters the government can solve all of
your problems or it causes all of your
problems you're more likely to fall into
a pit of extremism and extreme feeling
and rhetoric about the government that
makes the condition of the country a lot
worse rather than better I'm going to
talk about the latest example from the
Washington Post in just a second but
first let's talk about the folks who
work at your company so in my absence
Michael Knowles did a radio show for two
days and this has made me think should I
replace Michael Mills I mean I've been
thinking about that for quite a long
time if I do decide to replace Michael
Knowles I know I've been urged by others
to do so and only the better than angels
of my nature prevent this if I were to
do this I would go over to zip recruiter
comm right now because zip recruiter is
the best way to replace your bad
employees with better employees zip
recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job bores
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technologies zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter an equality candidate through
the site within the first day with
results like that it's no wonder zip
recruiter is the highest rated hiring
site in the United States and right now
my listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address zip
recruit com slash daily where again zip
recruiter com slash daily Wire Dai ly WI
re zip recruiter com slash daily Wire
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire get better employees get new
employees best way to
zip recruit calm / daily wire try it out
for free okay so not only is president
Trump worse than 911 according to the
editorial board at the Washington Post
President Trump is responsible for
hurricanes he rocks you like a hurricane
President Trump
apparently threw flatulence alone can
generate hurricanes here is what the
Washington Post says this is their
editorial board but don't worry they're
not generating a feeling of extreme
rhetoric with regard to politics in any
way shape or form politics is the be-all
end-all here's what they say quote yet
again a massive hurricane feeding off
unusually warm ocean water has the
potential to stall over heavily
populated areas
menacing millions of people last year
hurricane Harvey battered Houston now
hurricane Florence threatens to drench
already waterlogged swathes of the East
Coast including the nation's capital if
the category 4 hurricane does indeed hit
the Carolinas this week it will be the
strongest storm on record to land so far
north
president Trump issued several warnings
on his Twitter feed Monday counseling
those in Florida in Florence's projected
path to prepare and listen to local
officials that was good advice yet when
it comes to extreme weather mr. Trump is
complicit he's complicit apparently the
hurricane calls up the president and the
president's like listen I can't help you
out hurricane but what I can do is I can
keep my mouth shut I will be complicit
in your sins hurricane he plays a parent
so it used to be the Democrats blamed
the udin for the weather and we got that
from from that Democrat crazy person in
Washington DC the Jews were responsible
for the weather now President Trump is
controlling the weather it is this meme
on Twitter where you say something like
President Trump I can't believe he just
did flips through notebook and then you
land on some random thing I said flip
through I can't believe that he's
responsible for flips through notebook
dog abandonment right this is this is
that right
I can't believe President Trump is
responsible for flips through notebook
hurricane hey here's what they say he
plays down humans role in increasing the
risks he continues to dismantle efforts
to address those risks and now it should
be straight if President Trump signed on
to every leftist proposal on global
warming today it would have no impact on
hurricanes today none okay so that
hurricane would still be a coming down
the pike okay but they say it is hard to
attribute any single weather event to
climate change which is their admission
they have no way to actually attribute
this hurricane to climate change but
that's not going to stop them there is
no reasonable doubt that humans are
priming the earth
systems to produce disasters well I mean
there's some reasonable doubt about the
level to which humans are doing that and
the solutions that can be taken with
regard to it in fact in one second I'm
going to give you all the evidence but
the Washington Post continues they say
atmospheric research there Kevin Kevin
Trenberth a climate researcher at the
National Center for Atmospheric Research
co-wrote a may paper showing that
Harvey's cataclysmic wetness came from
the unusual hot Gulf of Mexico water
that fed the hurricane before it slammed
into Texas Harvey could not have
produced so much rain without human
induced climate change he and his
colleagues concluded now Florence is
feasting on warm atlantic ocean water
all of which by the way drove the
president to say that this hurricane was
extremely hard and extremely wet which
was very weird now Florence is feasting
on warm Atlantic Ocean water since the
Washington Post the ocean is warming up
systematically mr. Trenberth said
explaining through national national
natural variation can turn surface
temperatures up or down a bit the oceans
energy content is inexorably rising it
is the strongest signal of global
warming mr. Trenberth added it's very
weird how everything bad that happens is
an effect of global warming if it's bad
snowstorms it's an effect of global
warming it's bad hurricane it's an
effect of global warming again I'm not
somebody who believes that humans are
not contributing to global warming I
think that humans probably are
contributing to global warming by all
available evidence the question is what
is the climate sensitivity how much are
humans contributing to global warming
and what can actually be done about that
is maybe the best idea technological
progress as opposed to cap-and-trade
systems that are actually not going to
mitigate the effects of global warming
in any serious way but the the
Washington Post nonetheless blames the
President of the United States they say
the Trump administration has now
attacked all three pillars of President
Barack Obama's climate change plan
except that when Barack Obama had his
plan the Hurricanes were still hitting
the United States so this is quite silly
also it is worth noting that hurricanes
single major hurricanes in the United
States are at about their average
because the the it's funny the the
latest line that you were hearing for a
while what you're hearing from the left
was then the number of hurricanes is
increasing that's not true the number of
hurricanes is not increasing now they
say the number of hurricanes is not
increasing but the severity of
hurricanes is increasing so let's look
at the stats according to this guy James
Taylor who's president of the spark of
freedom foundation over at
forbes.com he actually went through a
decade by decade to look at the number
of major hurricanes hitting the United
States so from 2001 to 2010 seven major
hurricanes struck the United States
which is the 100-year average during the
preceding decade six during the decade
before that four before that four and
then from 1961 1977 okay from 1951 to
1969 from 1941 to 1952 in struck the
United States during 1931 to 1948 major
hurricanes struck the United States from
1921 to 1936 from 1911 in 1928 so the
idea that that we are now in the midst
of some massive upswing in the number of
radical hurricanes hitting the United
States the statistics simply do not bear
that out now is that a reason to ignore
whatever threats global warming is
posing no it isn't but to blame
President Trump who's been in office for
a year and a half for a hurricane
hitting is just insane it's just insane
and of course most people are only going
to read the headline anyway and the
impression they're going to get is the
president Trump simply doesn't care
about hurricanes our President Trump is
somehow forwarding hurricanes or the
rest of this sort of silliness I think
it is fair to say the media coverage has
has gone off the rails and it's not just
with regard to President Trump it's also
with regard to sort of normal Republican
candidates so the latest evidence of
this is the Washington Post again
they're the newspaper of the day going
after Ron DeSantis so on Sunday the
Washington Post had to Post reporters
put together a story that Ron De Santis
spoke at a conservative conference four
times between 2007 2013 and 2017 he
spoke at the David Horowitz Freedom
Center conference okay and and these are
usually they usually take place in
Florida I know this because this is
where I met Ron de Santos I met Ron De
Santis at this event it des the David
Horowitz Freedom Center in Florida
according to the Washington Post this
means that Ron de santis is no longer
fit for office because he spoke four
times a conference is organized by a
conservative activist who has said that
African Americans owe their freedom to
white people and that the country's only
serious race war is against White's is
they're gonna pick everything that David
has ever said that is wild and they are
going to now attribute it to Ron de
santis as opposed to when Bill Clinton
stands next to Louis Farrakhan and
aretha franklin's funeral and no one has
to answer a question about us now Ron de
santis goes and speaks at what is by
any measure a normal conservative
conference the wide variety of speakers
I mean we are talking about major
politicians in the Republican Party who
have shown up there it's not all people
who agree with David I know I used to
work at the David Horowitz Freedom
Center I was I was I was on the board of
the David Horowitz Freedom Center not
everyone who shows up agrees with
everything that David Horowitz says I
didn't agree with everything that David
Horowitz said but the Washington Post
around this long story suggesting that
because DeSantis had spoken at this
event
therefore he agrees with everyone at the
event which is just ridiculous it's just
ridiculous but that's the way the press
are going to treat our politics these
days and then they're surprised when it
feels like there's a violent upsurge in
American politics again they're not
responsible for that violent upsurge
unless they call for violence they are
responsible for raising the temperature
on American rhetoric to a dangerous
point I mean meanwhile nor MacDonald is
now in trouble because we can't have any
nice things we'll talk about that in
just a second first let's talk about
what you're doing for your stamps so are
you heading over to the post offices and
the post office is great but do you
really want to spend the time in the car
do you really want to spend the time in
line maybe you should just get all the
great services of the post office is
right from your desk and you can with
stamps comm with stamps con you can
access all the amazing services of the
post office right for me to ask 24/7
when it is convenient for you buying
prints official US postage for any
letter any package using your own
computer and printer the mail carrier
picks it up just click print mail you're
done it could not be easier we use it
here at the Daily wire offices they we
have their postage meter their digital
scale and we can tell exactly how much
postage we're supposed to print out you
print it onto a sticker onto an envelope
and then you just take all that and put
it in the mail and you're good to go
again we use it here I use it at home as
well right now use promo code Shapiro
for a special offer including up to
fifty five bucks a free postage digital
scale and a four week trial which is
pretty spectacular go to stamps calm
before you do anything else click on the
radio microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro again
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on that radio microphone at the
top of the home page type in Shapiro
that stamps calm promo code Shapiro for
that special offer including up to fifty
five bucks of free postage a digital
scale and a four week trial it's so the
culture wars continue in my absence
Norma Donald who's doing the only
Netflix special that I am actually
interested in these days he is now being
ripped up and down for an interview that
he did in The Hollywood Reporter
he
uninvited from the Tonight Show on NBC
Jimmy Fallon's tonight on NBC apparently
you're only allowed to go on NBC if you
are either an ardent Democrat or a
person who works for a company that
actually covered up for Harvey Weinstein
sexual abuses if you're one of the or or
worth with Matt Lauer if you've been one
of those then I guess you can go on
Jimmy Fallon show but if you express
sympathy for louis c.k or Roseanne Barr
then you're in serious trouble nor
McDonald was now in serious trouble why
because Norma Connell happens not to be
a radical leftist so he's talking to The
Hollywood Reporter and he was asked
about the emboldened of racism he said I
live in LA where I'm always faced with
the lunacy of the left I didn't know the
same lunacy existed on the right so I
never really bought into the notion that
everybody is racist because there was a
black president you know but the Sacha
Baron Cohen show has been a frightening
eye-opener
I was also in a bubble but in a
different way I guess everyone is an
effing idiot everyone is an ideologue
hopefully the pendulum will slow down in
the next four years and The Hollywood
Reporter person presses and swing back
toward liberalism because it's The
Hollywood Reporter and he says not
necessarily he says I'm happy the me2
movement is slowed down a little bit it
used to be 100 women can't be lying and
then it became one woman can't lie and
then it became I believe all women and
then you're like what like that Chris
Hardwick guy I really thought that the
blunt ends of the stick there and The
Hollywood Reporter said what about when
someone admits to wrongdoing and Norma
town'll said quite reasonably the model
used to be admit wrongdoing show
complete contrition and then we give you
a second chance now to admit wrongdoing
and you're finished and so the only way
to survive is to deny deny deny that's
not healthy that there is no forgiveness
I do think at some point it will end
with a completely innocent person of
prominence sticking a gun in his head
and ending it that's my guess
I know a couple of people this just
happened to and they asked who and
here's where he gets himself into
trouble he says well louis c.k and
Roseanne Barr are two people I know and
Roseanne was so broken up after the
show's reboot was canceled I got Louie
to call her even though Roseanne was
very hard on Mui before that but she was
just so broken and just constantly
crying there are very few people that
have gone through what they have losing
everything in a day of course people
will go what about the victims but you
know what the victims didn't have to go
through that what didn't and then they
asked you know what did the two of them
talk about he said they had a good
conversation and he said she's not a
racist everybody knows that she's not a
racist but she shouldn't have tweeted
the stuff that she tweeted he got all
sorts of flak particularly about the
louis c.k comment because the
implication seems to be that louis c.k
was innocent of any wrongdoing when of
course louis c.k
basically inviting female comedians back
to his room and then masturbating in
front of them and then apparently his
associates were calling up networks and
trying to get them to lose jobs but
there's no actual evidence that louis
c.k was engaged in that particular
activity Louie CK is back but the left
media is not interested in Louie CK
repairing his image by the way if you're
if you're Jimmy Fallon and you don't
want to have Norm Macdonald on for
saying this you will have Bill Clinton
on to talk specifically about
essentially being accused of rape and
that's totally fine you can't ask nor
McDonald's a tough question that's the
part of this that's so crazy let's say
you disagree with Norm Macdonald here
let's say you think what he thinks is
unreasonable why wouldn't you have him
on and just ask him about it the reason
is because we live in such a a
ridiculously censorious society that we
have to make sure that people like nor
McDonald's are never heard he apologized
for it and they're still not inviting
him on The Tonight Show and Matt Damon
made comments about me too he was
welcomed back into civil society there
are no accusations by the way that Norm
Macdonald has ever participated in any
sort of bad activity with regard to
women and yet he's being put on the outs
because he expressed sympathy sympathy
for Roseanne Barr or for louis c.k
people whose careers have been ruined by
allegations Roseanne Barr was ruined
because she tweeted out dumb racist crap
but should she be forgiven I think
probably louis c.k should he be forgiven
he seems to have expressed contrition
like right from the outset and then he
went away for a while I'm not sure what
else you want from him I mean you could
file a lawsuit it seems to me that a lot
of this if you really believe you have a
lawsuit against Louie CK perhaps you
should sue him if you really believe you
have credible allegations against Louie
CK perhaps you should sue them perhaps
you should take to the court because the
court of public opinion is a really
nasty place and destroying people's
lives and careers based on accusations
that you're not willing to back up in
court you're not even willing to try to
back up in court seems like a difficult
business to me it's hard for us to set
an objective standard if you're not
willing to take this stuff to court now
that doesn't mean that I don't believe
the allegations about Louie CK I tend to
believe the allegations about Louie CK
particularly since he admitted them but
it does mean that we have to have some
standard when normal talent says there's
no standard I don't think that he's
completely wrong of course there's no
standard here it's obvious there's no
standard here okay well meanwhile I want
to talk a little bit about the holiday
that you know before I get to the
holiday that I just celebrated
want to talk about Hillary Clinton so
this is an amazing thing Hillary Clinton
decided that it was necessary to step
into the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation
hearings while I was away so she tweeted
out this morning I want to be sure we're
all clear about something that Brett
Kavanaugh said in his confirmation
hearings last week he referred to birth
control pills as abortion inducing drugs
that set off a lot of alarm bells for me
and it should for you too and then she
continued by suggesting that that Brett
Kavanaugh was actually going to overturn
roe v wade and he hates abortion and
that's really why he said all this this
is a lie it is a lie that has been
debunked multiple times senator Kamala
Harris trotted out this lie over and
over and over again
The Washington Post gave it four
Pinocchios the reason that Brett
Cavanaugh referred to abort a fastens as
abortion inducing drugs is because they
are abortion inducing drugs and were
expressed as such in the Supreme Court
decision that he was citing but Hillary
Clinton comes out after this thing has
been debunked by her own favorite
publications and continues to parrot
lies again the the when it comes to the
culture wars the reason that so many
folks are with Norm Macdonald and
frustrated and with President Trump is
because the left refuses to call out its
own the left refuses to call out Joe
Scarborough for saying ridiculous things
the left refuses to call out it refused
to call it Hillary Clinton for saying
things that are obvious lies the left
refuses to call out Michelle Goldberg
who suggests that that Brett Kavanaugh
is is going to usher in The Handmaid's
Court and then you wonder why the the
politics are polarized it's ridiculous
okay now I do want to get to what I did
over the last couple of days so I was
absent for the last couple of days to
celebrate Rosh Hashanah Rosh Hashanah is
the beginning of the Jewish year so it's
the it's the Jewish New Year and more
importantly than being the Jewish New
Yor unlike sort of the secular new year
where you party it up and then you make
resolutions for the next year the Jewish
New Year is all about atoning for sin so
we are now in the midst of the High
Holidays which is typically used to
express sort of Rosh Hashanah and Yom
Kippur I'm about to explain to you why
I'm going to be absent for a bunch of
days coming up so this is why Rosh
Hashanah it was a two-day holiday that
happened Monday Tuesday and then a week
from today I will be out again for Yom
Kippur
that's the Day of Atonement that's where
you fast all day and you stay in
synagogue essentially all day and you
pray for forgiveness and then God
hopefully in scribes you in the book of
life and then about five
days after that four days after that I'm
out for another couple of days and that
one is for the holiday of the festival
of boo this is what it's called in
English called Sukkot in Hebrew and that
is the one where we sit outside in these
makeshift booths with palm fronds on top
to remind us of when we were sojourning
in the desert and then we conclude with
the the last couple of days of Sukkot
which is like a week after that there's
a last couple of days one is concluding
date Sukkot and the last one is Simchat
Torah which is when we celebrate the
completion of the cycle of reading of
the Torah so Jews every week read a
portion of the Torah and then over the
course of 50 weeks we go through the
entire Torah the five books of Moses and
then we celebrate let me explain why I'm
explaining all this to you in just one
second but first let's talk about your
hair look your look up top okay take a
look in there you think you're not
thinking about your hair right now I
promise you by the time you're looking
it's too late because you're already
losing your hair which is why you need
keeps maybe you've noticed you have a
little less hair than you used to have
but you're not sure there's a real
solution the thing is there are two
clinically proven medications that let
you keep your hair and now they are
inexpensive and easy to get you don't
need to lose that hair if you don't want
to which is why I'm telling you about
keeps for five minutes now in just a
buck a day you're not gonna have to
worry about hair loss ever again getting
started with keeps is really easy sign
up takes less than five minutes just to
answer a few questions snap some photos
a licensed doctor remotely reviews your
information recommends the right
treatment for you all without ever
leaving your couch keeps offers generic
versions and the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there something
probably tried in before we've never
gotten them this easily for this price
keeps it's only 10 bucks to 35 bucks a
month Plus right now you get your first
month for free which is a heck of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair to receive
that first month of treatment for free
all you have to do is go to keeps calm
slash Ben that's ke EPS calm slash Ben
again a free month of treatment at keeps
calm slash Ben keeps hair today hair
tomorrow
keeps calm slash Ben go check it out
right now okay well we are going to
discuss a couple of insane articles in
The New York Times and The Washington
Post and then the Wall Street Journal
rather with regard to religion which is
why I'm mentioning Rosh Hashanah I also
want to talk about Serena Williams I
missed that whole controversy while I
was out in the world continued while I
was out I just can't believe it I
thought the world was gonna stop
spinning and then I would be able to
come back and pick up where we left off
I'd be able to analyze last Friday's
Obama speech we've been great fun
unfortunately the world kept spinning so
we'll get to all of the latest news in
just one second but first go over to
daily where calm to subscribe 919
month get to subscription to daily wire
when you got that you got the rest of
this show live the recipe Enclave and
show live the rest of Michel moles is
awful show live you get all of those
things plus for your annual subscription
you get $9.99 bucks you get this the
very greatest in beverage vessels the
leftist years hot or cold tumbler you
know I'm not sipping from it today
because Jewish holiday it's a fast day
I'm really thirsty but you could be
sipping from it today all you had to do
was go over and get that annual
subscription over at daily wire.com go
check that out also when you subscribe
over at YouTube or iTunes then you get
to view our Sunday special well this
week Sunday special features the insane
and entertaining steven crowder who
stopped by for an hour i here's a little
bit of what we talked about hi i'm
steven crowder and that's Ben Shapiro
but I don't think you can see him right
now I am going to be on the Ben Shapiro
Sunday special show that's what it's
called right the Ben Shapiro Sunday
special yeah it's a big deal there's one
guest and we're gonna be talking about
some things may be off the beaten path
different side of Ben and myself that
maybe haven't necessarily seen before
and I think he's probably going to try
and make me cry
because I saw a show prep and we will
see whether whether that indeed
succeeded all you'll have to do is is
watch this Sunday all you have to do
subscribe at you tuber iTunes go check
it out we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so the reason I mentioned the Jewish
holidays is not just to prove to you
that I didn't just take days off for the
hell of it but also because we are
living in the midst of a sort of
religious schism that's happening in the
United States and really all across the
world with regard to Western religion
there are a lot of folks in the West who
believe that religion is what has held
back civilization people like Steven
Pinker people like Sam Harris people
with who I'm friendly and a lot of these
folks think that religion is the great
curse it's the great blight that if it
hadn't been for religion we would have
reached some sort of secular paradise
long ago now that ignores the fact that
once you get rid of religion and the
notion of absolute morality it's pretty
easy to slide into the secular
relativistic morality that leads down
the path to gulags and concentration
camps but the claim is that religion is
basically backward and that's the reason
religion is falling apart now that
religion is really falling apart and
what you see is folks on the Left who
want to maintain some semblance of
religion what they do is they've started
to infuse religion with a bunch of
secular humanist nonsense basically what
they want religion to be is a bunch of
secular humanist messaging with some
bagels on top if you're Jewish or with a
little bit of wafer and wine if you're
Catholic or if you're Protestant then
with a band I guess so here here is
there are a couple of pieces up
specifically about the Jewish holidays
in the New York Times and The Wall
Street Journal that are pretty
astonishing and telling about why this
religious schism exists and before I get
to these pieces I want to explain to you
why I think religion is important
because this is one of the questions I
get most frequently I'm an Orthodox Jew
obviously I wear a yarmulke I take my
religion extraordinarily seriously and a
lot of people say well Ben you know
you're a guy who promotes reason a guy
who promotes facts about feelings why do
you care about religion so much why do
you think all of these crazy things like
God spoke to people from on top of
mountain and all the rest number one I
think that there are real good rational
explanations for the existence of God on
our Sunday special a couple of weeks ago
he had an advisor who is a professor of
a Pasadena City College to make some
very good secular explanations for for
why he believes God exists but the
reason in reality that I believe in my
religion is because I believe the
judeo-christian civilization is the
greatest civilization in the history of
the world and it rests on twin
foundations those foundations are
Jerusalem and Athens the
foundations of judeo-christian
revelation the Old Testament as
promulgated to the rest of the world
from Christianity as well and the and
the notion of Greek reason which
provided us the idea that human reason
is capable of understanding the cosmos
without those two ideas there is no
science there is no Western civilization
there is no liberalism there is no
Western morality get rid of those two
key ideas Greek reason and
judeo-christian morality and what you
end up with is a hedonistic
deterministic society that is not
interested in investigating the cosmos
not interested in bettering life because
what does life matter anyway
I think this is one of the reasons that
what you're seeing in Europe with the
decline of religion is not an upswing in
beauty and harmony but an increase in
fresh in in fracturing an increase in
factionalism an increase in violence in
many cases the importation of people who
are actually having kids a decrease in
the number of children who are being had
economic struggle the rise of right-wing
nationalist groups in a lot of these
countries a lot of that has to do with
the European decision to abandon
religion long ago Judaism and
Christianity by extension provided the
world with certain basic truths those
truths include the idea that human
beings are made in God's image which
means that every human being has
inherent value that is not something
that you can find from an atheistic
source it isn't atheists who say that
they believe that I'm glad they believe
that I'm not saying anything is can't be
moral people they can I know a lot of
atheists are wonderful moral people but
ithi ism is not a philosophy that can
explain why every human being has value
any more than it can explain why every
ant ought to have value the idea that
God cares about human beings and that
what you do in the world matters that's
not something atheism can explain
because why should what you do in the
world matter you're a ball of meat
wandering around without any sort of
free will which brings us to Greek
reason right the Greeks were very
focused on the idea that the apotheosis
of human achievement was reason and
rationality and using your brain in
order to understand the universe Judaism
in Christianity they see they suggest
that unlike a lot of pagan philosophies
that the world actually has a systemic
order to it created by a rational God
and when you combine that with the idea
that human beings have the capacity to
understand their universe that's how you
get the pursuit of science but in other
words religion has eternal truths to
tell truths that are as valuable today
as they ever were
and yet what you are seeing is an
abandonment of traditional religion an
abandonment of of the synagogues and the
churches and an attempt to backfill
those synagogues and churches with a
bunch of secular humanist nonsense that
is not gonna bring anybody there so
here's a piece from The Wall Street
Journal today it's called it's by a
woman named Shane dear a so actually new
bakit when I was at Harvard Law she is
certainly of the left as she used to be
more orthodox I believe I'm not sure she
has anymore anyway the piece is called
goat yoga mosh pits glow sticks younger
Jews reinvent Yom Kippur now it's
important to recognize here Yom Kippur
is the most solemn day on the Jewish
calendar you fast for 25 hours you are
praying for nearly that entire time it
is an extraordinarily spiritual but
instead because they can't get
non-affiliated Jews into these into the
into their conservative inform
synagogues all these people are trying
these weird things so here is what the
cart achill says for 2000 years Jews
have spent Yom Kippur the Day of
Atonement in a synagogue abstaining from
food and drink fervently praying and
beseeching God to forgive their sins
this year some rabbis eager to woo
younger people to high holiday services
are holding programs in a beer garden
replacing deep reverential boughs with
goat yoga and celebrating the end of the
season with glow sticks in a mosh pit
and Rabbi Dan who started rosh hashanah
service called Baal Hashanah at the
Brooklyn Bowl a music venue and bowling
alley in Williamsburg New York says for
the millennial generation walking into a
synagogue can feel like a Civil War
Reenactment he said rabbi avi chef Ron
who actually does public affairs for
Goethe srl in New York which is north
and a groupie says it's a solemn time of
year to dispense with the solemnity is
to do violence to the very essence of
the days which is of course true
traditionalists assails rabbi Aaron
Potok who held the Yom Kippur program at
a Washington DC bureau garden last year
well no food or beer was served he said
fasting wasn't required of attendees he
said he felt validated when he packed
the beer garden with 140 people and had
a waiting list of 70 more there was no
prayer instead attendees discussed
themes of Yom Kippur such as mortality
repentance in the meaning of life
rabbi Patek says I am 100% convinced
that Jews are desperately looking for
ways to connect that are outside the
synagogue model know what he means that
Jews who are unaffiliated and aren't
interested in leading a Jewish lifestyle
are looking for something to connect
them back to eternal values and they're
not going to find it in beer gardens
they're not going to find it in mere
Gardens because I'm
some statistics about religion in the
United States in a second that
demonstrates that this is attempt by
Jews Catholics Protestants to run away
from traditional religion is actually
killing their religious conviction and
now so here here's some of these
statistics because again the Wall Street
Journal is pushing goat yoga and the New
York Times is pushing a piece called
celebrating Rosh Hashanah with less joy
more joy and a bit of gospel it's a long
feature piece on rabbi pari Berkowitz
who along with his sister rabbi Leia
Berkowitz runs East Side synagogue an
unconventional congregation on the Upper
East Side of Manhattan what exactly do
they do well the services are
freewheeling rollicking Affairs that
have the feel of a gospel church they
give evangelical type sermons and are
backed by a gospel choir that sings
liturgical music often in Hebrew the
songs can range from hymns and
spirituals to klezmer and pop and they
often spur congregants to form conga
lines down the aisles and my favorite
part of this is where they explain what
exactly they do here they talk about how
they they they say oi they say he says
the hereness rabbi pari Berkowitz told
congregants that someone asked why God
permitted rain on Rosh Hashanah they
said don't you have a connection
upstairs the rabbi recounted I said
sorry I'm in sales not management he
urged the congregation to wipe away any
negative associations from the past year
and to start the new year not with awe
but with joy he told them to exhale and
let go of all the oils of the past year
everyone went out of collective way he
directed them one two three oi
a spirited boy resounded in the worship
space so great
he also says during the surface the
Berkowitz is touched on social and
political themes including racism
anti-semitism black lives matter climate
change in homophobia yes this is exactly
what people are looking for out of
religion now here are some statistics
there because there are a bunch of
people left and right a bunch of people
left and right who keep suggesting over
and over the only way for religion to
survive is for religion to change with
the times religion has to not just apply
eternal lessons to new evidence which I
think is a good argument but to change
the religion utterly get rid of
fundamental conceits
about the nature of human beings get rid
of fundamental ideas about the nature of
morality and God instead basically
Judaism and Christianity these should
just bow to the secular idolatry that is
being promoted by a lot of folks on the
second left they should
synagogue should become places where all
you do is talk about black lives matter
and homophobia it's a DNC meeting center
except it's got a Jewish star at the
front or a cross at the front there's
only one problem with this it doesn't
work it doesn't work at all I mean there
are two problems one you're getting rid
of fundamental values but second there
is no actual draw to this
statistics show that these churches are
not holding anyone they're not holding
anyone hey I can tell you something at
my synagogue yesterday which is a small
stable okay it's kind of small synagogue
it was packed to the gills yesterday
it's packed to the gills every Sabbath
and it is filled with young people the
average age of Orthodox Jews in the
United States the most observant group
of Jews in the United States is 40 the
average age of Jews across the United
States who are not Orthodox is 52
Orthodox Jews are significantly younger
than non-orthodox Jews Orthodox Jews
have significantly more kids and then on
Orthodox Jews they average over four
children a family non-orthodox Jews
average less than two is there below
replacement rates the same thing is true
in the evangelical community people look
at polls and they say oh well the level
of people going to church and Protestant
in Protestant America is declining
mainline Protestantism is declining
evangelical Protestantism has gained all
the people who used to go to mainline
Protestant churches are either becoming
unaffiliated or they are moving over to
evangelical churches in the Catholic
Church you're seeing the same thing all
of these Catholic churches do drive by
and they have the rainbow flag waving
out front because it's a new diverse
Catholic Church or whatever a lot of
those Catholic churches are empty the
ones that are still full are the ones
that still care about what are
considered fundamental values if the
reason people that care about religion
the reason people are willing to
sacrifice for religion is because they
feel there's an eternal value to
religion and there is an eternal value
to religion and it is maddening to watch
as the media who hate religion top to
bottom start promoting this idea that
religion can simply be saved as long as
it parents the talking points of Hillary
Clinton that's not what's going to save
religion the only thing that's going to
save religion and by extension in my
view Western civilization is return to a
social fabric that matters a return to
eternal fundamental values that bring us
together it's really interesting Robert
Putnam who's a liberal sociologist over
at Harvard University he wrote a book
called Bowling Alone and in that book he
basically said that diversity ethnic
diversity doesn't in fact change
anything in the community except
protests marches and TV watching that's
his line
that happens protest marches increase
tv-watching increases but if you go to a
church where everybody it believes
essentially the same things about the
nature of man about the necessity to
care for your neighbor then diversity
helps then you see diversity across the
aisle but with a common set of
principles America is losing a common
set of principles they're back filling
that with politics and you're seeing it
happen in synagogues in churches and
guess what that's going to empty out the
churches it's going to empty out our
politics it makes politics paramount you
want a functional country you need more
people going to synagogue you need more
people going to church you need more
people who take religion and eternal
values seriously if you don't the
country is going to be in serious
serious trouble okay time for a couple
of things that I like and then some
things that I hate so I was in a very as
in a very preachy mood today so let's do
some things that I like and then some
things that I hate so I missed
apparently the whole Serena Williams
meltdown and I have some thoughts on the
Serena Williams meltdown so if you
missed it over the weekend Serena was
playing at the US Open the women's US
Open obviously because she's the
greatest women's player of all time now
the Raiders player of all time the
greatest women's player of all time and
Serena Williams the reason I say that is
cuz people on in ESPN keep saying she's
she should be considered the greatest
tennis player of all time which is
absurd okay it's just ridiculous it's
like saying Lisa Leslie should be
considered the greatest basketball
player of all time what anyway
Serena Williams is playing this woman
named uh is it Naomi Osaka I mean I
think Simon Osaka excuse me who's the UM
the up-and-comer she's 21 years old from
Japan and Serena was favored in this
match she's coming off of pregnancy and
things are not going well for her Osaka
blows her out in the first set and then
they're playing a competitive second set
and Serena Williams starts to lose her
cool because she's not playing as well
as she wants and she started yelling at
the chair Empire and here's exactly what
it looked like
I didn't get coaching you need to take
you need to make an announcement that I
didn't get coaching I don't cheat I
didn't get coaching how can you say that
[Applause]
you are Neapolitan after cheating in
midlife I have a daughter in st edward's
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
okay then she called the guy a thief and
then he gave her a game penalty so
basically he gave her he gave her a
warning I guess and then he gave her a
point penalty when she smashed her
racket which is mandatory and then when
she called him a thief and a cheater
then he gave her a game penalty when the
left said that she was totally right
about this she was totally right now if
Maria Sharapova had done this I highly
doubt that you get that sort of response
from the press that this is sexism at
work but Serena Williams is a hero to a
lot of people for some good reasons
that's fine
but she acted badly here okay she acted
badly here end of story and they're a
bunch and what I love is people who are
non tennis aficionados I'm not a tennis
aficionado so that means that I will
listen to people like the umpire in the
in the John McEnroe match I actually
gave a game penalty to John McEnroe I'll
listen to Martina Navratilova it seems
like these people know more about tennis
than I do but I like all the people on
Twitter who once saw a tennis match and
now they're like aww you know that's
just terrible that was sexism if a man
had done that he would have gotten away
with it really because John McEnroe
really didn't get away with it
right this is a piece by Richard ings
who was a who's the umpire in the
McEnroe in the McEnroe US Open his he
says his welcome to the job match
happened at the 1987 US Open I was the
chair umpire for the fourth round
Stadium court match between John McEnroe
and Slobodan Jovanovic when I issued a
warning point penalty and game penalty
against McEnroe the game penalty for a
string of obscenities against me came at
four or five costing McEnroe the set and
making the match once at all the
memories and scars my welcome to the job
match our fresh from even more than 30
years later Ramos will be going through
much of the same emotions he says that
all of this was exactly right he says
that the he says that Ramos did exactly
the right thing he says all players know
that destroying a racket on the court is
a mandatory code violation the game
penalty was triggered after Williams in
a lengthy tirade loudly accused the
umpire of being a thief stealing points
from her ramos let the tirade slide
showing great composure until Williams
accused him of cheating all players know
that publicly attacking the honesty of
the umpire is going to result in an
immediate code violation Ramos made
absolutely the correct calls as the
chair umpire in each of these three
incidents now if you mentioned that
Serena acted badly or that when serena
has been losing in the past sometimes
she loses her cool and acts badly
then this makes you some sort of sexist
and racist but I'm not the one who's
making this claim okay to other chair
umpires it's Martina Navratilova so
Martina Navratilova said this
Jim mr. Ramos effectively had no choice
but to dock her a point this is Martina
Navratilova probably if not the the
greatest women's player of all time
maybe the second greatest woman's player
of all time after Serena Williams she
says miss Williams opted to tie argue
about this she insisted she didn't cheat
she wasn't coached and therefore she
shouldn't have been docked but she
didn't it doesn't matter whether she
knew she was receiving coaching she was
being coached her own coach admitted it
after the match so at this stage she'd
been giving a warning one that couldn't
be ret dismissed retroactively Lee and
had smashed her rack in automatic
violation mr. Ramos effectively had no
choice but to dock her a point she says
and here's what Navitus says if in fact
the guys are treated with a different
measuring stick for the same
transgressions this needs to be
thoroughly examined and must be fixed
but we cannot measure ourselves by what
we think we should also be able to get
away with this is exactly right if you
think that the umpire should be harsher
on the men that's one thing if you think
Serina should be able to get away with
things because men have gotten away with
in the past I'm not sure how you argue
that and that in in politics we call
that what about ISM Jonathan last number
at the Weekly Standard makes this point
he says Serina has a history of lashing
out in big matches when she's getting
beaten by inferior players in 2009
Serina was getting work by kim chi stirs
in the semis at the US Open when she got
called for a foot fault again the call
itself was correct she exploded its high
rate against the female line judge that
included a physical threat in the 2011
finals at the US Open Serina was getting
beat by Sam Stosur when she yelled in
the middle of the point the chair umpire
called interference again correctly and
Serina exploded at her saying aren't you
the one who screwed me over the last
time are you coming after me that is
totally not cool don't even look at me
you're a hater you're very unattractive
inside again this doesn't change the
fact that serena williams is the is the
greatest female player ever but she
basically stole the headline from an
up-and-comer and that is really kind of
a terrible thing to do the thing that i
like about this is that there are some
actual tennis experts who are coming out
and speaking the truth and not being
intimidated by the by the wave of
publicity that has followed all of this
okay other things that i like so john
bolton who is the current national
security adviser he says that he says
that the united states is going to
withdraw the embassy the the Palestinian
and the Palestine Liberation
Organization which is the Palestinian
Authority has an embassy in the United
States he says that they are going to
get rid of it as well they should it's
terrorist organization here is john
bolton
the United States will always stand with
our friend and ally Israel and today
reflecting congressional concern with
Palestinian attempts to prompt an ICC
investigation of Israel the Department
of State will announce the closure of
the Palestine Liberation Organization
office here in Washington DC the United
States supports a direct and robust
peace process and we will not allow the
ICC or any other organization to
constrain Israel's right to self-defense
well good for a good for John Bolton and
and good for the Trump administration
which has been extraordinarily
pro-israel in every aspect as well they
should be
it's sad that this has become a partisan
issue because there is one side here
that teaches its children to murder
other people and there's one side here
that has repeatedly offered territorial
compromises in exchange for the other
side stopping all the nonsense about
teaching their kids to kill people so
that this is really not a hard issue and
the Trump administration gets it right
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate so this is pretty horrifying
apparently there's Washington
convenience store is near Seattle in
Auburn and a guy who was working behind
the counter collapsed the clerk
collapsed and the people inside the
store these two teenagers didn't call
for help instead they decided to take
the opportunity to rob the store so this
so I'll narrate the video because you
can't really hear the audio basically
you're gonna see that there is the the
clerk who's who's talking to them and
then he collapses you can see he faints
or something and the people he's talking
to then come back into the store and
start robbing the store they start
taking everything they can from the
store instead of calling the cops
they're walking around they don't care
this guy just collapsed and maybe dying
maybe had an aneurysm or a heart attack
they're just taking stuff even one of
the one of the messages of the Jewish
High Holidays and of religion in general
is that people are sinful creatures and
the people are capable of good and
people are capable of evil the notion
that that has become very popular in
American society and across the West so
that people are naturally good I don't
know how you can look at people and
possibly think that people are not
naturally good my two-and-a-half year
old boy is not a naturally good person
he's a naturally innocent person he has
the capacity for good but he's gonna
have to be civilized my four and a half
year old girl gets punished a lot went
bad hay people have to be civilized and
it takes it's because honestly we live
in a civilized civilization we live in a
civilization where violence is at
all-time lows where prosperity is
all-time highs do we look around say oh
people must be naturally good if people
were naturally good right we have
several thousand years of people beating
the living crap out of each other and
murdering each other by the millions and
now everything is BETT well because
civilization progresses and civilization
progresses because of that interplay
that I talked about a little bit earlier
on the show that interplay between
absolute morality and judeo-christian
morality and and Greek reason that
interplay cast across the ages is what
creates a civilization capable of
channeling people's selfishness toward
best efforts and capable of channeling
people's destructive tendencies toward
creative tendencies but the minute you
stop teaching children this your one
generation away from all of it
collapsing because the generation that
is not educated in morality a generation
that is not educated in decency will not
be decent it takes thousands of years to
build a civilization worth keeping it
takes one generation to destroy the
whole thing all you have to do is not
teach your kids that's all you have to
do and in an age when it's seen as nasty
and and judgmental to teach your kids
things it seems like that is becoming a
probability not just a possibility
unfortunately okay other things that I
hate so I have to talk about this
terrible terrible police shooting it's
not really even effectively a police
shooting but it's being treated as such
David French has a piece about it it's
about this guy named bottoms Shem Jean
who's a young black risk assurance
associate at PricewaterhouseCoopers who
was shot last week here's what happened
he was home alone in his apartment in
the Southside flats complex in Dallas
when a police officer named Amber Geiger
entered and shot him dead the precise
chain of events is somewhat disputed the
affidavit supporting Geiger's arrest
warrant states she believed she was
entering her own apartment which was
directly below his and laid out almost
identically she placed her key in the
lock the door pushed open the apartment
was dark she saw a large silhouette
across the room she believed she was
facing a burglar she drew her firearm
and gave verbal commands which jean
ignored she fired twice and only then
she says entered the apartment call
9-1-1 turn on the lights and realized
she'd made a terrible mistake but
apparently this doesn't square with
other testimony one witness reported
hearing the woman yelling let me in let
me in before the gunshots and a man's
voice saying oh my god why did you do
that after the gunshots police sources
are indicating that Geiger may actually
try to raise the fact that gene didn't
obey her
the defense that is not a defense you
come in if I come into your apartment I
started yelling at you and then I shoot
you I'm a murderer and the story doesn't
matter whether I'm a cop in my day job
hey you don't get to do that and this is
one of those cases where people should
be speaking out across the aisle because
the police department apparently took
its time about getting to this and the
investigation is pretty slow you know
there are actual problems that the
problems that actually exist in policing
I say this as a major supporter of
American police officers there are two
major problems in policing one is the
major problem that exists with regard to
guilty cops getting off because people
give too broad an area of discretion to
those cops and the other is a lack of a
lack of training not with regard to race
both regarding to proper use of violence
in particular circumstances in the
second one I think is is more common
among young recruits older people know
this I had a close friend of mine as a
police officer and he was talking to me
yesterday about how much of the job
involves just restraint just holding
yourself back and not doing things that
that you want to do and that's true but
when a police officer crosses the line
obviously we need to hold them
responsible the problem is we're having
the wrong conversation the conversation
we're having is about implicit bias and
secret racism in all of this the real
conversation we ought to be having is
about holding people accountable when
they actually do something wrong not
about maligning all police officers as
incipient racists who want to kill black
folks okay well we will be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest I hope
that you had a couple of decent days off
while I was off but we'll be back
tomorrow with all all all the news I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah all Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018